welcome to the Google cloud platform
education series my name is Jeff Davis
and in this session we'll discuss adding
machine learning into your applications
we'll be running a moderated Q&A during
the session so feel free to ask
questions using the ask your question
field at the bottom of your screen let's
get started we'll begin by doing a
series of demos will show the
capabilities of Google's machine
learning ap is and will show how you can
access those through simple web
interfaces or through incorporating them
using client libraries in your own
applications then we'll move on and talk
about machine learning as a whole on the
Google cloud platform we'll talk about
use of the api's and their capabilities
in pricing we will also talk about
Google cloud machine learning engine
which is the general purpose platform on
which you build train deploy and query
your own machine learning models we'll
finish up by talking about how to get
more information after this session how
to evaluate the opportunities that you
have for using Google's machine learning
features in your own products and again
we'll be doing QA throughout the session
so let's start with some demos we're
going to switch over to here and I'm
going to show you the capabilities of
each of the machine learning vision or
each of the machine learning ap is
through the simple web interface that
you can find online so we'll start with
the vision API the vision API allows you
to very easily identify characteristics
and content information about pictures
so let's take a look at that you'll
notice here I can select a photo I'm
going to pick a photo off of my hard
drive
and we'll drag this into the web browser
now this is making a machine learning
API call to division API and you can see
the whole range of characteristics that
this API can
give you information about so it's
analyzing the person's face and it's
trying to identify is the person happy
sad angry surprised and you'll notice
there's not a whole lot of positives
here we basically have found it doesn't
seem to be super happy doesn't seem to
be angry surprised or whatever if we
look at labels we can see that it's done
a pretty good job of identifying
appropriate labels for the photo so we
can see that it's a person we can see
that it's probably a surgeon not sure
where arm comes in but physician sounds
pretty good you can use this therefore
to actually go through a range of images
identify the content of the images and
take appropriate actions I'll show you
an application of some of these things
in my own demo applications it just set
you can get properties so for instance
this tells you what colors are used in
the photo so if you had an application
for instance that was going to scan the
internet for pictures of your product
and you wanted pictures that had certain
color schemes because those would look
good in your current marketing campaigns
layouts you could easily do that save
search basically identifies whether or
not the content might be inappropriate
so is it adult content is it violent is
it spoof content this is content where
it's sort of sarcastic in nature and
might not be appropriate for your
application and then the JSON here this
is the actual response of all of the
characteristics that get returned to you
by the vision API so what does this all
have to do with machine learning
well what Google is doing is they are
taking tons and tons and tons of images
and corresponding labeling information
and they're training a model
specifically at identifying the
information about faces labels
properties inappropriate content and so
forth on images so this is a very
purposeful API but it's one with wide
and common applications lots of
applications could make use of this and
so they make it available
if we look at the speech API again you
have a similar demonstration notice the
speech API can work in a variety of
languages I'm going to use English and
I'm just going to speak to the web
browser we need to plan a q1 Business
Review and our top priority for q2 is a
proof of concept on the professional
Edition and an upgrade you can see that
it has actually taken it's transcribed
what I had to say and this would be
super helpful for instance if you
incorporated this into applications that
your customer success managers or your
sales rep views it's hard enough to get
those folks to enter good data into your
CRM system this makes it easier they can
just talk into an application have it
transcribed and automatically added
let's look at the cloud translation API
so I'm going to switch this from English
to Chinese I can't type Chinese so it's
not going to make a lot of sense and I'm
actually going to choose to translate
this into Spanish ok so then if I say we
need to schedule a business review
you'll notice that it translates it on
the fly
although I should spell things correctly
okay and the primary goal for q2 is to
perform a proof-of-concept on Pro
Edition and arrange and upsell
now you'll notice that there are two
different translations available there's
the standard edition in the premium
edition the premium edition is intended
for larger blocks of text and rather
than doing sort of a word by word or
short phrase by short phrase translation
it's looking at the context of the
overall document and is able to use
large quantities of text and the context
in order to make more intelligent
decisions about its translation the
fourth API that I'll show you is the
cloud language cloud natural language
API and what this does is it allows you
to enter text and it will analyze the
text and sort of draw three different
sets of insights so you'll notice the
first is what's called entity extraction
so when it looks at the text it's able
to identify Google is an organization
Android is a consumer good sundar is a
person the Consumer Electronics Show is
an event right so it's able to actually
go through and identify entities and
then link to information on the internet
about those entities on the other hand
if I said I really like Google Hangouts
better than anything else
it was clearly as good as for instance
you'll notice it's able to extract that
zoom is an organization Google Hangouts
is a consumer good anything is sort of
interesting so not perfect but pretty
good now in addition to being able to
extract entities which is really useful
for instance if you want to scan a bunch
of tweets about your product and find
out what other products are mentioned in
the same tweets that way you get a
better idea of what your customers
consideration sets are you might also
want to know how they feel about your
product so
we take the same sentence and we have
the natural language API do sentiment
analysis and you can see that the
overall sentiment is positive so this
goes from negative 1/4 really really
negative to positive 1/4 really really
positive so this is a point four which
is good and these this number gives you
a strength of the feeling so it's really
good but you can be sort of a it's
really good but it's not that important
or it could be really good and it's
really important so you'll notice that
the first sentence was 0.42 point four
and the second sentence it was actually
slightly better now if I said it was
almost as good as zoom and we analyzed
that you'll notice continues to be
really strong if you say I hit this my
video was grainy and my session kept
getting disconnected probably because I
was hijacking my neighbor's Wi-Fi not
that anybody would actually do that okay
again if we look at the sentiment you'll
notice overall sentiment is negative and
in fact the word hate clearly denotes
really strong dissatisfaction also
fairly strong overall magnitude of
sentiments the third category of
analysis that the natural language API
performs for you is a syntactical
analysis so this actually does a bunch
of stuff it's a little beyond my
expertise but it's able to sort of
indicate how the various words are
related to one another and what parts of
speech each one is and so forth so this
could be useful but the first two are
the ones that I've seen more typically
used within applications by the
customers that I work with
so obviously the functionality is really
cool
it's great at all but you can't really
do business by going to each of the
special purpose machine machine learning
API and working interactively with the
UIs
so what you really want to do is you
want to have your developers be able to
consume these insights from the machine
learning api's within programs so what
we're going to do here is I'm going to
shrink this down and we'll shrink this
down and I've got a couple of examples
here okay
so you'll notice I've got some code in
my Finder window I'm going to actually
look at that code in my code editor here
and so the first one that I'm using is
the speech API so the speech API I'm
using an example that Google has
provided us and I'm using the Google
cloud Python client libraries and so
what I'm going to do here is in quick
start you can see that I'm going to
import speech from google cloud library
I'm going to create a speech client I'm
going to open a file and this is a
recorded file that's very much like the
content that I spoke into the web page
and I'm going to open the file read it
in as an audio sample and then I'm going
to ask the speech client to actually do
a synchronous recognition extract the
content out of the audio file and
transcribe that so let's see if that
works that's not the one we want that
let's see if this is what we want
that's the image API so we'll come back
to that in a second so this let's run it
if all goes well we should get output
that contains the transcript of the
audio file that I recorded earlier and
so you'll see the transcript says we
need to schedule and deliver in I didn't
speak as clearly as I might have a q1
Business Review primary goal in q2 is to
do a proof-of-concept and close the
opportunity for the pro upgrade okay not
bad now again I'm doing this from the
command line I haven't incorporated it
into a full app yet but this shows you
how straightforward it is to actually
incorporate so if we go to the vision
API we have a similar example so the
QuickStart here basically says let's
import the vision library instead of the
speech library let's create a vision
client let's find the wakeup cat file
and let's feed it to the vision API and
see what information we get back and
specifically I want to look at the
labels I don't need to see all the other
stuff I just want to see the labels so
let's go back I'm going to close the
speech client and let's actually open
the wake up cat so you can see what the
image looks like there's our cat and
we're going to feed this image to the
vision API and see what it has to say so
it takes a moment or two to run and it
comes back and it gives you the labels
this is similar to the set of labels
that were displayed in the web UI during
the first example that I gave you so
this identifies the picture as having a
cat the cat being a mammal the cat
having whiskers the cat being a small to
medium sized cat as opposed to a big cat
like a lion or at
this could be a cat-like mammal so that
would be like a Lynx or something like
that something that isn't a cat but
looks like a cat and then animal shelter
is the last one and I'm not sure which
components made it look like the animal
shelter perhaps the industrial blinds in
the background but probably lower level
of confidence in that prediction
okay these are great again little code
examples but Jeff I want to see
something meteor I want to see something
actually live and running and show you
all of googles machine learning prowess
being brought to bear in a real business
problem okay so let's take a look at a
live application this application is a
customer success application it's used
by a post sales customer facing team to
monitor customers engagement and
experiences with the product and to
intervene proactively to help drive
better outcomes for the customer and
better upsell and renewal for the
proximate so forth in product and hand
is a video conferencing product people
do calls when they're done with the call
they can leave a rating but they can
also leave a text message a certain
chunk of feedback and we want to be able
to analyze whether or not that feedback
is positive or negative and we want to
be able to deal with feedback in a
variety of different languages so what
I'm going to do is go to the comments
page and what we have here is a
proof-of-concept we have a list of
comments these comments are provided in
different languages so you notice the
first comments in English the second
comment is in French
the third comment is in Spanish the
fourth comment is in Chinese and the
fifth comment is in Swahili so clearly
we have customers all around the world
now if I were an English only customer
success manager and I was just looking
at the raw feedback provided by
customers
I would have no idea what four-fifths of
my comments meant but notice here I am
getting the original comment and that
I'm also getting an English translation
so this is saying it was good the audio
was a bit squeaky this was saying I was
disappointed that there's no support for
Linux obviously happy camper with this
comment another happy camper here
additionally not only does this
translate from the original language to
English it also performs a sentiment
analysis and color codes that so I can
easily take a look
I can see for instance that this clearly
seems to be a strongly happy customer
this customer is alright this customer
is not at all happy and so forth now
again this is just a proof of concept
it's a it would be less useful to have
an individual looking at this
interactively than to be performing say
a mass analysis where you take all of
the comments from all of your users over
the last 30 days and you a granade them
looking at sentiment analysis and that
you identify what percentage of comments
are strongly negative versus sort of
medium versus strongly positive and you
could perform outreach to customers that
are strongly positive in order to
cultivate champions whereas you could
reach out to unhappy customers to try to
do account recovery or solve whatever
problem they're running into
implementing this was just as easy as
the quick little demos that I gave you
previously so if I go in and I look here
you can see this is where I put the
sample comments and up at the top I've
imported to client libraries so I've
imported the translate library from the
Google cloud client and I've imported
the language library and then I make a
translate client and a language client
and then to do the translation you can
see the first thing that I do is detect
the language so I don't know ahead of
time what language to come
is in and I have to tell the translation
API what language to translate from and
to so the first thing that I do is I
detect that and then I actually do the
translation and that I'm going to output
the translation similarly I use the
natural language client to create a
document from the text that was provided
now you'll notice I'm using the
translated the English content for some
languages you can actually do this with
the native language French for instance
native detection with the natural
language API is not available so I
translated everything into English and
then I do a sentiment analysis and I'm
going to use the sentiment score to
output now obviously there isn't any
sort of error handling you're going to
want to if you were doing production
code it would be more robust but this
gives you a sense that in 10 or 15 lines
of code I am now tapping in to this
highly-trained ever-evolving API for
language and for translation and I get
the benefits directly in my application
with very little real development time
this legitimately took me from the first
time I did this this took me less than
an hour to read the documentation figure
out the api's write the code and start
consuming so for different AP is we have
vision speech translation and natural
language and these all can be very
easily incorporated into your
applications tomorrow with a small
amount of code so really you just have
to think about what use cases you can
leverage now let's say that you need
something more specific to your
environment so vision is nice speech is
nice but let's say you want to do you
want to do damage assessment you want to
look at images of roofs and based on the
damage to the roof you want to identify
what the cost is going to be to repair
that this is being done by insurance
companies now they actually will fly
drones the drone will go
fly-over take video footage that footage
gets uploaded to a machine learning
model the machine learning model can
then actually do estimates on how long
it will take to repair and how much it
will cost to repair in order to do that
obviously you can't use one of these
very general purpose machine learning
api's you would have to build your own
model
I'm not going to demo that because if
you actually look let's do cloud ml
engine demo we've got some samples here
so the if we did the introductory
example for cloud ml engine so this is
building taking a data set from the
Census and building a model that will
predict based on census demographics
what your earnings will be I just want
to show you real quick what's entailed
in setting up this model so you'll
notice this article goes on for a little
while it's not actually terribly hard to
make this intro work but it would take
significantly longer than we have today
to get everything built to train the
models to test them and then get up get
them up to speed a big part of this
beyond what you would see in this
introduction is that you actually have
to collect the right data you have to
sanitize the data you have to format the
data the quality and quantity of your
data is really critical if I were to
demo it what I would probably do is do
another demo here and what you would
want to do is actually predict turn so
what customer success teams are really
really interested in is looking at these
renewals and finding who's coming up for
renewals that you might not get a full
renewal on and that's kind of the holy
grail of customer success is being able
to identify potential turn candidates
and then intervene in enough time that
you can make it go away
clearly Google doesn't have a model
already created and serving for my
particular customer base
I would have to create my own I would
also need a relatively good set of data
from a relatively significant number of
customers so since this is a demo app I
don't have all of that at hand but I
think you get the point so hopefully
this has really begun sort of getting
you thinking about how you could use
either the canned api's or your own
models in your applications so let's
talk a little bit more about the general
capabilities of machine learning across
Google cloud platform so in the bottom
row here you have the machine learning
offerings and the four items on the
right you should be quite familiar with
right here's the vision API - speech API
the natural language API and the cloud
translation API Google also just did a
video insights API where you can
actually now extract information similar
to what you get out of division API for
still images you can actually do this
out of videos now and then on the left
is the cloud machine learning engine so
it's the Google cloud machine learning
engine which is quite a mouthful
but it's also quite a handful of
Technology basically it uses the
tensorflow
model development framework and it
automatically provisions and builds the
clusters necessary to train your model
and then you can deploy your model and
run predictions against the model the
top row here is a bunch of tools used in
big data and analytics workloads and
remember I said that the care and
feeding of your data that you feed into
your machine learning models is
absolutely critical and so you're going
to want to leverage bigquery data flow
data proc data lab in order to collect
your data organize your data sanitize
your data and get it ready to feed into
the cloud machine learning engine so a
few details about the API s and about
machine learning engine so the cloud
vision API is accessible through a
simple REST API it can detect labels
logos landmarks and faces
so an example that we might use in my
customer success application is I might
want to actually find all of the photos
of my product in certain verticals and
so what I want to do is I want to find
our logo but I then also want to get
labels that indicate whether it's an
industrial environment or a medical
environment or a social environment and
that way I can actually extract those
photos and put them in collateral aimed
at those verticals it can do OCR so you
can obviously extract the text content
out of the images if you run any sort of
a platform where customers are creating
and sharing content with other customers
you clearly are concerned about what
gets posted because you don't want
inappropriate content this is either
violent content or things like nudity to
poison the well in your community so you
can actually run all of your stuff
through the Google cloud vision API
before it gets submitted and you can use
this to take appropriate action if
inappropriate content happens and
obviously all the image attributes so
again this is if you want to find all of
the files in your giant photo repository
that meet certain conditions in terms of
color scheme for instance the pricing
for making use of the vision API is a
dollar fifty per thousand units and you
get an initial allotment of units for
free the second API that we talked about
was the speech API the speech API
supports recognition of up to 80 plus
languages it can be real-time or
recorded so we showed you real time when
I was speaking into the web site and you
can build that functionality fairly
easily Google actually makes a quiet
library it's often optimised to detect
the active speaker even when there is
surrounding noise this is really
important because very often when
somebody speaking it's not in an
enclosed studio but rather they may be
out on the street
they may be in an open floorplan office
and you want to be able to extract the
speech from the primary speaker and
ignore the background noise and
background conversations if you are in
an environment where you have a lot of
technical jargon or words that would not
be common in everyday speech you can you
can actually provide word or phrase
hints to the API so you can say for
instance that gas and energy terminology
that isn't in everyday conversation
might be common in the audio inputs that
you're providing and so you provide a
list of those phrases and words and it's
more likely that they will be recognized
and like the vision API it can actually
identify inappropriate content and
filter that out pricing for the Google
Cloud speech API is six tenths of a cent
per 15 seconds with the first 60 minutes
being free the Google Cloud translation
API can work with a hundred different
languages as I noted in the example that
I gave in the customer success
application it can do automatic language
detection the model is being
consistently upgraded by Google so it's
constantly getting better you start with
a maximum quota in terms of the number
of characters that you can spend but you
can easily adjust this up if you do
large amounts of translation and as I
noticed there's a premium edition in the
premium edition is less for translating
phrases and short quantities of text
rather for translating large blocks of
text and it is able to use the contexts
throughout the block to do sort of
better narrative translation pricing
here starts at $20 per million
characters translated the Google Cloud
natural language API as we saw can do
sort of three types of insight
extraction it can pull out the entities
and identify who those entities are it
can do sentiment analysis with
the most common use that I've seen in
the field and it can do some tactical
analysis it supports multiple languages
not all languages of origination are
supported so for instance French isn't
but you can try it in your own language
and if you don't if it doesn't work in
the default language that you would
prefer you can actually translate it to
English and do that pricing starts at $1
per million units with the first 5,000
units being free now these again are
Google's hand models they're heavily
trained they're really really strong but
they are general-purpose they don't
necessarily solve the problem that you
are tackling so you can build your own
models now the way that Google has built
their models is they have said large
quantities of data so an example here
would be training the vision API you
feed it a bunch of images and with each
of these images you provide an
appropriate label you run a very large
well-crafted data set through a
mathematical model and once you've
trained it what's happening is the
machine learning process in this case
running an ml engine it's going to
continue to tweak this mathematical
model until it has a very high
probability that if you put in a cat
what's going to come out is the label
cat
now obviously you probably don't want to
replicate the vision API you can just
pay Google by the image but what I would
do here for say the customer success
application is instead of images I would
give descriptions of customers so for
every customer of our product when did
they buy how big a company they are how
much did they buy initially how much
have they used the product is usage
going up as usage going down and I would
give as many features as I think are
likely relevant and then I would
indicate whether or not these customer
renewed or scaled back their purchases
for up sold and the goal is to create a
model that instead of spitting out cat
instead when I give it a new customer
with a bunch of features describing
their interactions with our company and
product they give me out a label that
indicates high probability of renewal or
high probability of churn to do this you
would you again you would use cloud
machine learning engine you define your
models in tensorflow
which is a machine learning model
development framework this is a portable
framework so you can develop your models
and run them on cloud machine learning
engine but you can also take them and
run them on whatever other
infrastructure you want the machine
learning engine is tightly integrated
with other Google services so it's easy
to pull in data from Google Cloud
storage for instance or you could do a
bunch of your analysis in bigquery and
dump the results out into your machine
learning engine project they have a
feature called hyper tuning so hyper
parameters are parameters that are not
sort of feature related on individual
items but rather how deep do you want
the neural network to be how many leaves
do you want high for tuned will
automatically adjust those parameters
for you and find what choices are going
to give you the highest level of
accuracy in your models it's quite
scalable so you can go ahead if you do
that demo that I showed you sort of the
example that Google gives you you start
by doing training with a single instance
but you can scale that up and do
distributed training you can you can
train your model using a single instance
you can train your model using ten
instances you can train your model using
75 instances and so on and so this
allows you to feed more data into your
model training faster I mentioned that
the models are portable and again the
whole training and deployment and use of
your model is a fully managed service
you don't have
to worry about acquiring hardware you
don't even have to worry about spinning
up individual VMs you simply turn the
dial say you want to train and Google
will automatically scale out the
resources as necessary pricing for ML
engine starts at forty nine cents per
node hour for training and forty cents
per node hour for prediction plus
there's an additional ten cents per
thousand predictions charge again if you
want to have an idea of the cost that
your project may incur ahead of time go
and use the pricing calculator so
whether it's api's or building your own
models on cloud ml engine you want to
thank where can I start using machine
learning to make my applications better
there's tons and tons of applications I
was at next last week and as I listened
and sat in on the talks about machine
learning I kept thinking of all of the
software that I've developed over the
last five years and all the places that
I could use machine learning so
sentiment analysis on comet churn
prediction upsell prediction conversion
predictions all tremendous things so we
had done a little bit of data science at
my last company where we determined it
if a customer got to one hour of calls
every day for every box that they had
purchased that they would be a customer
forever they never their users kept
going up and they would renew and we
found that any customer who didn't hit
that milestone would actually churn and
it was very high correlation so it was
fairly good predictability but what was
this it would have been a lot easier
that was a lot of sort of manual work in
building processes on local resources
was this we would be much better off
feeding as much data in with a bunch of
features and having it build a model for
us so after today's session is you begin
to play with the api's where you begin
to explore building train
deploying and using your own models
where do you look for additional
information you as always you start with
search so if you type in Google cloud
and the API name then you're going to
get information about the vision API or
the translation API if you type in
Google Cloud ml and a topic then you'll
get information about the machine
learning capabilities with cloud ml
engine so for instance one of the things
that Google does is they support the use
of GPUs for training your your models
using cloud ml engines so if you type in
Google Cloud ml GPU you'll get articles
that tell you how to do it how much it
costs stuff like that
again you have sort of the standard
organization of documentation for cloud
ml engine so you've got the six
quadrants you've got a QuickStart which
that's super quick that's just basically
installing tensorflow and being able to
do something very very very basic then
you have two how-to guides in the
tutorials and this is where you're going
to get into that relatively lengthy
walkthrough and some other better
examples the documentation for the API
is is a little different than this but
again if you just search it'll take you
directly to the articles that you're
looking for so that's it for this
session thanks so much for joining us I
hope you found it interesting and you're
inspired to incorporate machine learning
capabilities into your own applications
we'll be sending you an email with a
link to a code lab and you can use that
to get some hands-on experience with
machine learning capabilities on Google
cloud platform we'd love your feedback
so feel free to provide feedback through
the UI on your screen and thanks very
much